je vous rassure je vais pas vous parler
de hambourg guerre par contre si mon
accent vous exècre la direction a mis un
cageot avec des tomates à disposition
alors vous avez le droit voile alors
effectivement je suis ici d'une famille
de cuisiniers restaurateurs hôteliers
depuis sept générations et j'ai
énormément de choses qui m'ont été
transmis
grâce à cette atmosphère qu'on trouve
dans l'hôtellerie la restauration
donc nos winstub lobby octobre en alsace
en suisse en autriche ont toujours
acheter
je t'aime tech c'est une table des
habitués et tout petit j'ai eu
l'occasion de pouvoir sur les joues de
mon grand-père assister à ces
discussions que les anciens avaient donc
il ya déjà une transmission qui m'a été
acquise dans les années 60 alors que
c'était une décennie de grande ouverture
d'esprit et ben moi je me suis plongée
nord le passé grâce à ses anciens grâce
à ses aïeux qui ont vécu leur jeunesse
avant la première guerre mondiale et
j'avais eu l'occasion encore dans ma
famille puisque on était souvent à la
table familiale
quatre générations autour d'une table ce
qui est quand même très très rare donc
moi ma soeur mes parents mes
grands-parents et un oncle ma grand mère
qui était vraiment un bourlingueur
intelligence et je vais vous raconter
son parcours qui m'a quand même beaucoup
beaucoup influencé dans la vie et
surtout qui s'occupait de moi le jour de
congé de notre hôtel restaurant et bien
sûr il m'a raconté ses grandes histoires
avec toute la pudeur propre en alsacien
dont vous savez bien que l'alsace avis
qu énormément de de vie passionnante et
de vie à tragique et ben ce personnage a
pu traverser le siècle en ayant vécu
toute cette cette vie étonnante
il a commencé sa carrière militaire dans
la cavalerie prussienne les fameux bulan
qui me racontait je vous parle
maintenant de ce qui me racontait donc
il a une période pendant trois mois sans
déceler sans se déshabiller sans se
déchausser jusquen une fatigue extrême
il a appris son rétablissement pu
rentrer dans la nouvelle arme qui était
l'aviation militaire extrêmement c'était
vraiment très très difficile pour entrer
dans cette nouvelle arme et photos à
l'appui puisque j'ai hérité de tous sont
passés de toutes ces photos il m'avait
raconté tout ça il a vécu des
expériences extraordinaires et surtout
pour revenir maintenant aux côtés du
goût il était colons à madagascar après
la guerre mondiale en une grande
exploitation qui dirigeait où y planter
du tabac y planter de la vanille plantes
et du gingembre totalement inexistant
chez nous en france dans ces années là
ainsi que du manioc et tout ce qui
s'ensuit est en pleine brousse bien sûr
tous ces remèdes et un savoir faire lié
à un peu débrouillard débrouillardise
après ça pourquoi je suis devenu un
historien et ben d'une part par ça et
puis faire le lien avec la cuisine
puisque ce transfert de la cuisine a été
acquise depuis très jeune parce que
cette atmosphère qu'il y a pas seulement
à ce fameux jeu tom déjà dans un
restaurant c'est également le fait
d'être en communion parce qu'on peut
parler de la communion avec des
cuisiniers avec des apprentis qui
avaient tous quatre cinq ou dix ans
puisque moi mais j'ai été élevé dans
cette atmosphère
alors ça n'a absolument rien à voir avec
les émissions télé ce que voyait
actuellement top chef et tout ça il y
avait vraiment une transmission et un
savoir faire qui se faisait par les
anciens par les apprentis qui me donnait
cette passion de la cuisine donc je
parlais de la cuisine je parie de
l'histoire
et après pourquoi les remèdes et malévoz
mais je me suis retrouvé effectivement à
23 ans avec un ulcère
pourquoi un ulcère pas parce que
effectivement dans le métier il ya de la
tension il ya de la pression
on mange sur le coin d'une table on
avale ont subi bac s qui avait comme
solution pour un ulcère et ben y en
avait pas beaucoup à part changer de
comportement mais je ne voulais pas
abandonner mon métier et je me suis
souvenu d'un livre puisque je vous
disais bien que j'avais tout hérité de
mon oncle on arrive on plutôt un livre
sur la santé de la pharmacie du bon dieu
écrit par maria très bonne bien sûr un
livre en allemand c'était une
autrichienne qui a été effectivement
traduits en français 20 ans après et il
ya effectivement des remèdes et des
recettes qui m'ont vraiment influencé j
ai trouvé bien sûr le remède pour mobile
sert je me suis guéri pendule sert tout
seul qui était tout simplement le
matricaire la camomille qu'on trouve
près des champs de blé ou dans les
champs de blé cesser les grandes fleurs
jaunes donc là je me suis inspiré de ce
livre pour découvrir d'autres herbes
aromatiques d'autres façons qui en fait
ton j'ai bien vu que c'est pas
uniquement des remèdes mais c'est aussi
des recettes parce que c' est
naturopathe autrichienne était
influencée par hildegarde de bingen qui
était une très grande
visionnaire du 12e siècle tout le monde
s'est référé à cette grande visionnaire
qui dirigeait un monastère déjà à
l'époque est actuellement quand on parle
de médecines parallèles ou plutôt
médecines douces
on fait souvent référence à cette
personne donc voilà mes trois axes dans
ma vie dans mes passions j'ai eu
l'occasion
grâce à mon métier et grâce à ce besoin
de découvrir grâce à ce besoin de
chercher ce que mon arrière on le
faisait déjà être un petit je m'entends
bien petit bourlingueur par rapport à ce
que mon en vente on l'a fait j'ai eu
l'occasion par mon métier de pouvoir
faire des semaines gastronomiques des
dîners de gala
des représentations de mon magnifique
magnifique région qui est l'alsace
d'ailleurs vous voyez est le petit logo
ça c'est le blason d'alsace donc
malheureusement l'année prochaine il
faut que je l'enlève puisqu'on fait
partie de l'alsace lorraine ardennes
champagne
malheureusement tout le col ne suffit
pas alors on m'a trouvé une idée on va
marquer rolande voilà je sais pas si
c'est encore d'actualité l'année
prochaine mais bon c'était une
supposition
on les tomates sur la base si je
commence à dire des conneries n'hésitez
pas donc on revient les sur les choses
un peu plus intéressante donc historiens
j'aime bien ce petit mot historiens mais
par contre dernièrement le directeur de
la drac qui tombe la direction régionale
de l'archéologie en alsace ma vie mais
ce que vous faites c'est de
l'archéologie expérimentale
c'est vrai qu'avec tout ce que j'ai à
qui j'ai fait énormément de de dîner sur
l'époque romaine parce que c'est ce qui
m'intéresse le plus et j'ai même fait
suite à ce qui m'avait dit une
exposition sur six mois remède et
recettes de l'antiquité
alors il faut savoir qu'à l'époque tout
était lié
donc cette cuisine santé était tout à
fait connu parce qu'un médecin n'avait
pas beaucoup de possibilités pour guérir
il vous donnait effectivement plusieurs
remèdes qui en fait qu'on des recettes
toujours à base de miel toujours à base
de garonne toujours à battre de poivre
du miel et des boissons qui sont des
boissons d'assemblage tels que nous
connaît encore un peu l'hypocras qui est
à une boisson moyenâgeuse
mais les romains faisait beaucoup plus
si faisait les du moule zoom il faisait
des du défaut tome qui ressemble
beaucoup aux vins de maury qu'on connaît
dans le sud de la france ou des genres
de porto donc une concentration et tout
ça c'était des aliments dont tous tous
ces aliments en fait contre ces boissons
et hellemmes et des délais des
médicaments
donc je vais parler de quelque chose qui
s'appelle le garum un béluga rome et
guay mixte rares extraordinaire parce
que j'écris aussi des articles dans un
bulletin archéologique est toujours axé
sur la cuisine surtout de l'antiquité et
alors ce gars sommes à une ex à une
quelque chose d'extraordinaire il faut
savoir qu'il n'ya pas beaucoup
d'historiens pas beaucoup de l'écrivain
qui s'intéresse aux côtés culinaires la
recherche culinaire
parce qu'en traversant les siècles je
vous suis rendu compte qu'en fin de
compte toutes les recettes on les
retrouve encore ce notable transformé
par les siècles transformé par
différents pays
la cuisine romaine vous l'a retrouvée
presque fini presque à l'identique dans
l'ancien empire de byzance donc grecs
turcs libanaise chypriote 1
voilà vous avez le 6e round 6 euros
naquit le houmous
vous avez des trucs à base de fromage
blanc demande tout ce qui s'ensuit alors
je reviens sur le fameux garonne qui
était donc une genre de saumur fait avec
du poisson gras déposés dans des vases
et grâce au sel et des épices cela
donnait effectivement une fermentation
lactique
mais grâce au sel qui est tendance et
antiseptiques
il n'y avait pas de putréfaction donc
après avoir massé raissa pendant un
certain temps on a retiré le jus qui
donnait le leak amène appelé aussi
garonne et la partie les résidus dur
était le alex alors le alex remplacer le
sel était un assaisonnement et ce alex
on le retrouve encore actuellement dans
tous les bassins méditerranéens et le
garum on le retrouve partout
il a été inventé par les mésopotamiens
par les grecs commerci
et par les phéniciens il a traversé
lorient il y arriver en inde en aide
il y a énormément de gars home locaux
les anglais colonisateurs ont découvert
séance égard aux locaux eh ben ils en
ont fait le beau chace tâche à la sauce
présente dans nos cuisines occidentale
depuis un siècle dans les mets et même
dans les boissons
vous avez déjà vu injustement tourner un
peu de votre chaise de chasse aux il y a
les thaïlandais qui ont le temps plein
et il y a les indonésiens qu'ils ont
lequel jacques marie mûri ou marie et
alors ce fameux garonne a traversé le
pacifique et arrivant aux états unis
transformer parce que par quelques
judicieux les italiens avec un peu de
tomates un peu de sucre un peu d'épis ce
qui nous donne une 16 est une sauce
aigre-douce qui n'est rien d'autre que
le ketchup présent sur toutes nos tables
du monde entier voilà l'origine de ce
gars homme qui a traversé quatre mille
ans en france on le trouve sous le nom
de pie salah le pis à l'a qui est un
genre de alex donc qu'on retrouve
effectivement c'est des anchois marinés
qu'on met dans la pissaladière voilà et
comme ça je pourrais vous raconter des
heures toutes les origines de tous les
plats de l'époque romaine
on a eu beaucoup beaucoup de fausses
informations sur l'origine des pâtes
tous les écrivains disent ah mais c'est
marco polo qui a ramené les nourrices
qui a ramené l'ehpad de chine
totalement faux dans le livre de rapides
sus notre fameux happy dessus ce qui a
écrit un codex au 1er siècle qui est le
plus vieux livres de cuisine jamais
diffusé parce qu'il est toujours
il a été transcrit jusqu'à l'invention
de l'imprimerie et après il a est
diffusé à un tel point qu'il est
toujours encore édité bien sûr ça a été
un certain temps ma bible et je me suis
énormément inspiré et j'ai pu recréer le
fameux celle romain il ya une quinzaine
d'années que je vous ai ramené
aujourd'hui et qui étaient à la fois un
médicament
ce sel romain était un médicament était
un mode d'assaisonnement et à monet des
changes
ça valait son pesant d'or celle romain
était valait son pesant d'or
vous entendez bien donc que vous allez
voir que vous allez le prendre après sur
la paume de la main et vous avez juste à
val et vous allez voir une diffusion de
saveurs une diffusion de plein de choses
et c'était effectivement médicaments
donc les autres fausses idées étaient
aussi tout simplement christophe colomb
comment ça se fait qu'il a inventé a
découvert l'amérique attend parce qu'il
était un peu plus intelligent que les
autres pas non je voulais trouver une
route plus plus proche mais pour faire
quoi pour trouver de l'or où trouver les
pommes de terre
vous trouvez les tomates ben non ça
c'est devenu pratiquement s'entend après
puisque la pomme de terre
l'or des incas les tomates viennent du
pérou voilà un ballon il est allé
trouver une île c'est un domingue haïti
il a ramené quoi dans son premier voyage
deux éléments que nous utilisons encore
tous le potimarron ou potiron et les
haricots qui était dans l'antiquité les
flat vol qu'on trouve encore maintenant
c'est des tout petits haricots blancs
avec une tache noire
vous avez les flageolets vert mais tous
les haricots les cocos les copeaux de
soissons et tout ce qui s'ensuit
ça c'est christophe colomb qui l'a
ramené en premier et
bon ah oui là je me perds un peu
donc il y a effectivement comme il y
avait tellement de choses je vais
pratiquement tous dit c'est pas possible
oui alors effectivement actuellement il
faut faire très attention sur la
mondialisation du goût cette
uniformisation qui est très très
dangereuse pour notre savoir
parce qu'en fait quand ce que nos aïeux
et puis ont essayé de faire c'est de
toujours aller dans l'évolution du goût
dans l'évolution de l'amélioration de
l'alimentation de effectivement d'éviter
une vie trop fade as il faut savoir que
un chevalier un haut blanc se devait de
mourir à cheval l'épée à la main les
conquêtes les guerres qu'elle risque
richesse cherchait-il est-ce que c'était
l'or est ce que c'était agrandir un
empire est ce que c'était pour conquérir
pour montrer qu'on est plus fort que
l'autre
ben je peux vous dire qu'avec mes
recherches peut être sûr et certain que
depuis l'antiquité depuis qu'alexandre
le grand a fait un parcours phénoménal
vers l'orient pour aller en inde pour
récupérer effectivement les épices qui
était déjà une très grande rareté
ils voulaient dominé la paire slap r ce
qui est effectivement un un ennemi
héréditaire de la grèce et de l'as rome
il faut savoir que toutes les conquêtes
romaines pendant toute l'antiquité les
romains se faisait et ce dès faisait
selon les conquêtes de lorient pour
dominer cette route de la soie
vous savez que les romains avaient déjà
de la soie et ben la soie a été ramenée
de shing personnes connaissaient la
fabrication de la soie
mais il n'y avait pas que la soie il y
avait le lapis lazulis la fameuse
couleur bleue que les égyptiens avaient
déjà qui toujours encore une couleur
très très très noble
c'était donc en afghanistan qu'on
appelait à l'époque de l'antiquité la
batterie yann et vous aviez tout les pis
les poivres les épices que nous
connaissons encore actuellement enfin
qui reviennent sur la table je disais
bien avant que le gingembre le
connaissions pas dans les années 60
eh ben le poivre étaient présents sur
85% des recettes d'apicius le gingembre
étaient présents sur 30% des recettes le
corian les feuilles de coriandre que
nous avons réappris à travailler grâce à
la cuisine chinoise la livèche quelqu'un
connait la livèche la livèche c'est le
mahdi en suisse chez nous à l'alsace et
tout ça c'est une herbe amaguiz sa
tirelire pour le prenais ça sent le mari
lemagit où le mari et femme avec mon
accent alsacien pour les tomates sont
encore là bas rhin si quelqu'un j'ai dit
alors une épice qui est très commune
chez nous un peu moins ici la france de
l'intérieur comme on dit en alsace qui
serait c'est comme ça qu'on dit un vieil
france joue un peu plus intelligent
élise la vieille france donc je reviens
encore effectivement sur cette culture
alsacienne que effectivement né au
centre de l'europe et qu'on a eu
plusieurs cultures cette culture nous
est parvenue malheureusement grâce à aux
guerres grâce effectivement toutes ces
guerres qui ont en fait compte grâce à
ces guerres à ces nobles qui
guerroyaient tout le temps à chaque fois
ils ont amené une autre et pis un autre
aliment
il faut savoir que les cerises les
pêches
les abricots les pamplemousses les
oranje tout ça tout ça ça vient de
lorient et chaque fois ça a été ramené
les dernières trouvailles sont tout
simplement le qui vive
on n'a pas eu besoin d'une guerre pour
ça mais moi j'ai connu l'apparition du
qui vit qui arrivaient en fin des années
70 la tomate a apparu en france qu'en un
siècle ou deux siècles après l'italie
acclimater en espagne acclimater en
italie et la pomme de terre pourquoi là
pomme de terre est apparu en france
je crois qu'ils vont aller jeter une
tomate
donc je reviens sur nos fameuses pommes
de terre la pomme de terre à une
histoire assez singulière mais véridique
ce que je veux dire maintenant c'est
l'avancé la vérité il faut savoir que da
pays à l'autre ils accepter ou refuser
de manger tel et tel produit
c'était comme une dictature de
l'alimentation il faut savoir que la
france était toujours en guerre avec
l'espagne l'allemagne les flandres
charles quint louis xiv louis 15 par
contre louis saez et est beaucoup plus
intelligent il avait effectivement une
personne qui s'appelait parmentier un
agronome je pense que c'était un
agronome qui lui a eu pas beaucoup de
chance parce que après une carrière
militaire où il était prisonnier dans le
hanovre dans le brandenburg pendant
plusieurs années après la guerre de
succession d'espagne en 1764 à bailly
s'est retrouvé pendant quatre ans à
bouffer des pommes de terre les
prussiens avec les pommes de terre en
prusse pays beaucoup beaucoup plus
pauvres à l'époque faut pas oublier que
voltaire est allé se réfugier chez le
roi de prusse fameux frédéric ainsi que
tous les jeunes français déjà 100 à 150
en avant
mais par contre c'est quand même rester
un pays pauvre par rapport à la france
mais la france a quelque part refusé
effectivement ce diktat que je reviens
nouveau sur le diktat alimentaire pour
ne pas manger la même chose que son
ennemi héréditaire mange tels que les
allemands les espagnols et tous sont
donc en fait l'hôte je vais conclure
cette petite histoire de pommes de terre
si louis saez et parmentier qui portait
une petite fleur de pommes de terre à la
redingote avait pu faire accepter la
pomme de terre
il n'y aurait jamais eu de révolution
française il aurait évité les 2/3 famine
qui ont précédé la révolution
vous savez vous comment parmentier à
fait pu faire accepter enfin cette pomme
de terre
20 17 190 91 ce n'était pas fameux non
plus eh ben il a fait pas planter des
pommes de terre dans les faubourgs de
paris dardé par la garde nationale
mais il leur disait bon s'il ya des gens
qui viennent piquer les pommes de terre
les scellés faire laissez les faire et
c'est effectivement ce qui s'est passé
et c'est grâce à cette anecdote qui
écrit ça vient pas de moi bien sûr
les français ont commencé à adopter la
pomme de terre est devenue un pays de
pommes de terre consommation n'est
peut-être pas aussi exagéré que celle
des belges qui dépasse quand même encore
et c'est toujours encore véridique et
les allemands bien sûr sur un des grands
consommateurs de pommes de terre
voilà donc je voulais encore surtout
dire pour clore
oui je sais alors epa est au matin c'est
bon si je suis trop long la facilité des
échanges grâce à notre technologie des
remèdes et des recettes qui sont
totalement identique 1 j'espère que ça
va contribuer à enregistrer scheer notre
quotidien et la culture culinaire de la
table doit continuer à contribuer dans
la paix du monde et la qualité de la vie
commence dans l'assiette
voilà merci